I haven't had a job since 1954 okay I
always heard that writing was the
hardest work of all yes but I'm not
going to come complain one controls
one's own time would you please tell me
what books you have authored with
respect to Bank on the I I wrote thirty
three years ago a book called Wall
Street men and money and then was out
doing other things writing about other
subjects mostly until 1972 when I went
to work on a book called the bankers
that was published in 1975 on which the
American people at their pleasure and in
their wisdom spent almost 5 million
bucks that year some of which sticks to
the author and persuaded me to continue
writing about financial subjects there's
in a book called the fate of the dollar
that came out in 1980 and a book called
the money bazaars that came out in 1984
and I have written a number of pieces in
periodicals I write a column two or
three times a month for American Banker
which is a daily paper and indeed it was
a column entitled Panama and the banks
which I believe called mr. Blum's
attention to my interest in this matter
which grows out of our continuing
interest in Bank Secrecy questions in
the way banks can be abused in the
importance of supervising the activities
of Bank will keep that dirty word
regulating out for a little I think we
probably have the necessary regulations
but we don't have anything like the
necessary supervision that's my
understanding that you have an opening
statement that you'd like to make and
I'll try to get open that I try to
organize it last last night as I came in
rather than the column which is of
course available to you the basic point
is that banks can be used to make big
money ads anonymous as small bills and
we have therefore required our banks to
report cash transactions of $10,000 or
more and we have vironment once you
place that in perspective that
requirement went in recently didn't it
actually they began to enforce it
recently it goes back I think into the
70s the
it's the Bank Secrecy Act is 1970 and I
believe there was an amendment
subsequent to it basically this
requirement goes back to 1970 we do have
procedures which are established by
which law enforcement officials can
access bank records when there is
probable cause to see the money flow as
the product of criminal activity we do
that more or less routinely in this
country there are ways in which District
Attorney's US attorneys can in fact get
access to bank records it's not easy
shouldn't be easy but it can be done and
these these procedures can be and have
been extended internationally the three
most notorious bank secrecy havens once
upon a time was Switzerland the Bahamas
and the Cayman Islands all three of
these now have treaties with the United
States permitting competent us Authority
on submission of evidence to look at the
books of locally chartered banks my
understanding is that these treaties
were not easy to get but in the case of
both the Bahamas and the Cayman Islands
they came around
only after it was made clear to them
that the US government had the power to
disrupt their tourist trade quite
substantially if they would not do so we
had a flap only a year ago when the
Treasury Department someone had an axe
and sudden access of zeal and was as a
result lil as a result he left the
department shortly thereafter decided
that he wanted a similar provision in
our tax treaty with the Netherlands
Antilles let me ask you if you could
just if you could speak a little slower
and a little more clearly I think it's
gonna be a little easier to follow you
it's hard you can have these notes but I
don't know how much they'll help you but
they're there there was this effort to
get a similar treaty with the
Netherlands and Antilles and the
Netherlands Antilles which has been a
haven for money which doesn't wish to
have its provenance known resisted it
and we attempted to take certain tax
benefits away from them which then
provoked a great flap and the person who
wanted to do what was gone but my
understanding is that the Treasury
Department is still indeed and still has
the intention of cancelling aspects of
that treaty because the Netherlands
Antilles will not give us access and
that that that matter still pens
at least this is not a radical crusade
our treaty with the Swiss was negotiated
by the Ford administration the treaties
with the Bahamas which turned out to be
so useful in the insider trading
investigation was completed during the
first Reagan administration
there is nothing political about this or
shouldn't be even before we had such
treaties William French Smits Department
of Justice successfully subpoenaed
records from the Bank of Nova Scotia
branch in the Bahamas because the Bank
of Nova Scotia clearly fell under the
rubric of the Bank Secrecy Act of 1970
ordering the secretary of the Treasury
to compel the maintenance of records of
foreign financial transactions by quote
persons doing business in the United
States any bank in other words which
does business in New York can be under
the Bank Secrecy Act of 1970 compelled
to keep such records and to make them
available to US law enforcement
authority indeed if you read the Bank
Secrecy Act of 1970 it I would think not
being a lawyer compels the secretary of
the Treasury to order banks to do this
though the secretary of the Treasury and
the bank regulators have not been
willing to exercise their powers under
the Act except in extraordinary
situations like this Bank of Nova Scotia
murder Panama meanwhile with our
encouragement to a large degree has
promised 100 odd bank branches that are
charted there both freedom from local
taxes on their international efforts and
absolute secrecy we have sat still for
it indeed in these waning days of the
second Reagan administration the worry
seems to be that following the current
unpleasantness in Panama the banks will
pull out which is something which from a
drug smuggling point of view I'm afraid
one would have to consider rather
desirable unless there is a major reform
Panama today is by general agreement the
locus of the largest money laundering
operations associated with cocaine they
use the dollar therefore there is a a
demand for for currency it is extremely
difficult to track money because it goes
right into the economy there
it does not go into bank vault it does
not have to be converted into local
currency to be used there is a virtually
bottomless pit of demand for $4 which of
course can be satisfied by flying in the
money from the sale of narcotics in this
country if we are serious about stopping
the flow of this poison into our society
steps to make the transfer of the money
more difficult or very nearly as
important as steps to make the movement
of the drug itself more difficult so
long as the dollar is the vehicle
currency for world trade no bank
anywhere in the world can survive
without access to the chips computer in
New York that's the that's the Clearing
House interbank payment system through
which virtually all international
payments flow at this point it is within
the power of the Comptroller of the
currency and the Federal Reserve to deny
access to the New York Clearing House to
banks that fail to cooperate with the
investigation of drug smuggling and drug
sales and the laundering of drug money
it would seem to me that one of the
first steps that could be taken and
could be taken very simply is for this
government under the powers that the
regulator's already have to insist that
anyone who wishes to use Fedwire or
chips must make available to law
enforcement authority under proper
procedures information relating to the
movement of money in their foreign
branches and particularly their
Panamanian branches one hears the
objections echoing private banking is
the most profitable thing that our big
banks do they think it's not really
because it's the it's it's the Avenue by
which capital flight enables countries
that borrow to get the money out so they
can't pay you back we will lose business
to Europe
let the Europeans have the drug business
it will weaken the dollar as a vehicle
currency fine the cost to us of the
worldwide use of the dollar as a vehicle
is now considerably greater than the
benefits we have so long derived from
seniority in fact the greatest single
danger to economic stability in the
years ahead is the use of a debtor
country's currency as the vehicle for
trade especially when one factor in the
continuing invitation is is the
continuing in
and offers to the Congress and the
executive branch the continuance of
fiscal irresponsibility but the first
question is cocaine getting rid of
Noriega will not it seems to me give
democracy any kind of chance in Panama
so long as the cocaine money flows
through Panamanian banks and is
available for the corruption of the
Panamanian armed services and whatever
elected authorities we wind up with
Panama clearly must begin to print its
own currency and stop using ours it is
enormous Lee in our interest to do so
and of course they will first as a
matter of self-respect after the present
humiliating business and it may be
desirable but it's a very humiliating
experience for them and second to enable
investigators to begin to trace dollar
flows through Panama as they cannot when
the basic demand for the dollar is
internal within the Panamanian economy
we are not immune from corruption in
this country either the stain of cocaine
addiction has already spread widely in
this society a little inconvenience in
the banking system is a tiny price to
pay for controlling and perhaps reducing
that state and it can be done by making
money flows much more public much more
available to constituted authority I
think the legislation is already in
place and people have to enforce it
thank you very much mr. mayor I
appreciate that I think both senator
d'amato and I would like to ask you some
questions and abano service and I think
on the Banking Committee and it's very
familiar with some of these matters let
me just ask you so we can try to
simplify the language that you used here
and I want to do that so that we lay
people who don't deal with banks every
day can really grasp the the bottom line
of what you're saying just tell us why
is it that panama the cayman islands
hong kong something why are they so
attractive to the smugglers why don't
they just come to New York well partly
because here the the possibility exists
that well first large large cash
payments really must be reported we have
begun policing that large fines and very
embarrassing news stories have been
around for people who have violated the
rule that you must report every cash
transaction of more than ten bucks so
the moment you have a reporting
requirement there's a deterrent oh
there's a very substantial deterrent you
call attention to yourself in ways that
you don't wish if you're in this at the
moment you have that kind of deterrent
in one banking center you create
pressure on those who use cash as their
as their stock and trade to move
somewhere else where they can continue
to do it is that accurate yes but we
facilitate that by not distinguishing
between those countries which permit us
to get access to such information and
those countries which do not in the use
of the u.s. payment sister saying is
there are some countries on which we've
been willing to be strict and other
countries in which we've had a totally
loose open situation which has
encouraged narcotics dollars to flow
there in some ways Panama is the worst
why well my understanding is that when
when you know the first of the
presidents that Noriega deposed Nicolas
our dato Barletta
was can I just interrupt you there I
apologize I have an emergency phone call
here which I do need to take senator
d'amato could you continue in this I
will be right back
should I finish the answer to that one
gentleman this was the idea of Nicolas
or Dido bore a letter who later became
president of Panama our elected and was
deposed by general Noriega before he
deposed del Valle and he thought that it
would be very useful the Panamanian
economy a major source of jobs to have
Panama become a banking center and he
sold the idea in this country to
basically to a ID and we were quite
helpful to them in getting a banking
industry started this is second hat I
have not personally investigated this so
I've checked up on it after I was told
it and it's understood that the easiest
way to get banks to come is to is to
guarantee them a complete secrecy then
the business they don't what it's it's
one one doesn't want to put this too
unpleasantly but what senator Kerry said
is basically right but if you are if you
are requiring reporting in one
jurisdiction there are people who like
the money that comes with not reporting
who go seek out other jurisdictions
Panama did extremely well on this also
Panama was particularly useful as I
noted because they use the dollar and
therefore large dollar flows into and
around Panama are not noticeable the way
they might be are in Colombia itself
where basically people do still use a
local currency as their as what they
what they spend for their needs so that
you have to to to take an example
entirely on the other side if if
somebody in the in the Federal Republic
of Germany acquires dollars he changes
it into marks quickly marks are likely
to appreciate in value and where he
lives they spend marks if there are
there are places in the world where
people who acquire dollars tend to keep
them in dollars but even there usually
if you want to pay for a nice house
you're going to do it in the local
currency in Panama nobody ever has to
change the currency nobody ever has to
go to the central bank to say give me
your pesos given me your yen give me
your marks I want to use them are and
therefore any movement of dollars can be
accounted for by the needs of the local
economy this is this is something that
we have now found useful but it's not
good for Panama over time and in
connection with cocaine smuggling and
such things it certainly isn't good for
us because it provides too easy a a
screen behind which dealings can be
hidden
let me ask you mr. mayor if you were to
make a number of recommendations as it
relates to dealing
more effectively with money laundering
if the Treasury wanted to call upon you
for your expertise in these areas what
recommendations would you make not only
as it relates to Panama but but in in
general are there other any areas in
which we could improve the law
enforcement efforts in attempting to
deal and attempting to prevent money
laundering on the scale that it takes
place now well yeah the the business I'm
in is a is a Brandeis business I believe
that sunshine is the best disinfectant I
believe in reporting requirements now we
have as and I take some pride as Senator
Kerry is indicated being on the Banking
Committee and I wanted to know wasn't
easy in getting the requirements as it
relates to reporting and the penalty
provisions for money-laundering
increased significantly so that now a
financial institution that violates the
law willfully as it relates or its
employees as it relates to failure to
report a transaction of $10,000 or more
stand liable not only for a a fine but
for the total amount of that transaction
that is substantially greater than what
had been the penalties heretofore so
we've attempted to to stiffen that but
are there there other areas in which we
can improve this in terms of foreign
banks that maintain operations in the
United States
I should think we could make it a
requirement of their children to do
business in the United States to have
access to the Clearing House computer to
have access to the American payment
system that they that on once once again
one does not wish to do this thing
promiscuous Lee but on submission of
satisfactory evidence that money
laundering is occurring that the money
that is moving is the proceeds of
activity that would be criminal in the
native country of the country that has a
branch here that these books shall be
open to investigators for them to be
able to track the money but I
think you must be that stiff about it
you must say that you will not be
permitted to have a branch operation in
the United States you will not be
permitted to move money through the
chips computer unless you make this
information available why do the banks
need access to the Clearinghouse system
supposing you were to say all right you
have X Bank you've refused to agree to
this therefore we're going to deny you
access to the Clearinghouse with that
incapacitation oh yes but what is it
it's an essential element it is an
essential element the the reason I sort
of paused when you first ask the
question is that there exists a
communication system the Society for
worldwide interbank financial
telecommunications I think that's right
Swift which is based in Belgium which in
theory could be turned into a payment
system through the use of correspondent
banks but the efforts to approach that
have failed so far I think they would
continue to fail and you simply cannot
finance your countries world trade at
this point in the game unless the
payments flow through this central
international computer which is in the
basement of a building on Broad Street
which is the Clearing House interbank
payment system computer which is a
subsidiary of a New York Clearing House
regards to that let me depart for a
moment in the absence of the Chairman
and take this opportunity to touch on a
subject that I touched on late yesterday
afternoon and that is in regard to the
attempts of Duvalier or excuse me of mr.
Noriega general Noriega to literally
loot the banks of some 170 plus million
dollars of deposits that are now
deposited in American institutions he
has put forth an order which would
require the Bank of Panama to call in
all of these dollars all of these
deposits and and once he had
a access to Bank of Panama had access to
these monies he could he would literally
be able to transfer this into a into
cash it is estimated and we may have
trouble stopping him from getting the
initial 20 million dollars which the
Bank of Panama has on its hands at the
present time but it would be able to
draw on the depositories of some
representing accounts of some eight
hundred thousand Panamanians and it's
estimated that there's at least a
hundred and seventy million dollars now
there has been a question because
president Duvalier has indicated that he
would impose new economic sanctions such
as cutting off trade with the Panamanian
people etc that wouldn't increase the
level of their sacrifice but he says in
a letter which I have just received
today and I share with the committee off
copies made dated April 4th he said I am
emphatically of the view however that
the financial squeeze should continue
and should be enhanced through further
measures my government will continue to
take every action available to it in
Panama and abroad to deny resources to
the illegal Noriega regime I believe
that the United States should and will
continue to cooperate with this
financial effort in this regard I
specifically urge the United States to
take every step possible to ensure that
assets of the Panamanian banks which are
held in the United States not fall into
the hands of Noriega I also urge that
cash or cash equivalent items be
prevented from transfer out of the
United States to Panama for possible use
by Noriega is regime and I urge that the
steps be taken to ensure that no cache
of cash equivalent items be paid to the
Noriega regime by the United States
companies these steps would include a
ban on the conduct of business by US
banks in Panama and a prohibition of tax
payments or other transfers by the
United States companies the Noriega
regime and this is signed Erik Arturo
Duvalier president the Republic of
Panama by one Sousa his ambassador legal
representative president Duvalier in the
United States the fact is if the
the administration and the president in
particular fails to invoke the
provisions of the IEEPA that is the
international emergency economic Powers
Act that there will be they will take
place a transfer of 170 million dollars
plus to the Bank of Panama now well that
sets up something very extraordinary
possibilities and you indeed the
American dollar may no longer be
official tender of Panama but he would
use the hundred and seventy plus million
dollars to back a new currency which
they are in the process of attempting to
print and to establish they've said they
needed about six weeks they've already
been about three weeks into this with
the help of the of the Cubans point
number two I have requested for Senator
Kerry myself a briefing by the State
Department I spoken to assistant
secretary Elliott Abrams as it relates
to reports of a brigade of up to 1200
men having flown into Panama we have no
independent knowledge of this State
Department them is looking into this and
I've and I've asked that we we get a
briefing in relationship to this let me
proceed if I might with some questions
is a Panamanian economy that depends on
the banking industry a healthy economy
should there be more diversity is this
if we were to for example insist upon
the kind of disclosure that would make
it more difficult for money the money
laundering operations to continue as
they have in the past and Panama what
would happen to those banks would they
continue to operate is there is there
legitimate business there for years I
heard of Panama as being one of the
emerging growing areas of commerce and
of trade is this a fiction or was it
simply did it come about as a result of
the money laundering I think primarily
it came about
as the result of money laundering but
that doesn't mean that there aren't
functions there you and I come from a
state which is not a well-placed to say
that the financial services industry is
not a good source of economic strength
the the the problem in a place like
Panama is that it becomes very
corrupting to the entire society when
the reason why a business is there is
that it's good for crooks and there is I
think a trade off now when we started
the international banking facilities in
this country the IBF the offshore banks
we destroyed quite a lot of the
legitimate use of offshore but of
offshore banks are the growth of the
Central American economies worried to
occur the fact that there is expertise
in Panama if you if you look at if you
look at the European situation there is
more banking business done in London
than there is in the whole rest of the
common market put together and the
reason for that is that London has
developed an expertise in a position it
is not impossible that Venezuela and
Colombia and the Central American
Republic's would find continuing use for
honest Panamanian banking operations I
do know I think that there would be a
reduction in size but it might be better
for Panama over time this stuff does
explode on you after a while
nevertheless I think one must face up to
the fact that if as part of our attempt
to stop the movement of cocaine money
there may be some loss of Panamanian
jobs and we should perhaps undertake
efforts through our aid organizations to
ease the pain of that when it when it
occurs certainly Panama would be better
off with a smaller more honest banking
system and with the people employed
there doing other work let me ask you
what difficulty of any would for example
the loss of the Panamanian
banking institution as a haven for money
laundering which it would appear
certainly at the very least it has been
disrupted since the banks have been
closed for the international drug
cartels to turn to other areas how would
they do that what about the ease of
doing that and are you aware of any
areas that they may have indeed turn to
since the money laundering through the
Panamanian banks if the present time has
been has been closed or stopped
well when ar111 comes back to Luxembourg
pretty quickly in some of these
Luxembourg yeah the I I think I do not
have personal knowledge of where drug
people go to put their money I think
that that you've got to Lance this this
boil in New York where the dollars move
you've got to Lance it at Fedwire and a
chips and you've got to have the Federal
Reserve System on board and then you can
control it everywhere simply getting it
in Panama it's you know it's the old
pipe late you'll push in the bump it'll
come up somewhere else but it's since
right now so much of the machinery is
dedicated to the using of Panama I
suspect that there's been some
disruption and some problems and getting
the stuff around which they are in
process of solving now it would be good
to keep them off balance and it would
also be good to try to see to it that
when this thing in Panama ends however
it ends they cannot go back to business
as usual with the movement of cocaine
money mr. mayor do you believe you'd be
in a position to offer a series of
regular recommendations to the
regulators as it relates to dealing
specifically with this issue so that
they might be able to make the kinds of
changes that would impede if not to make
this certainly more difficult money
laundering per se I think we want
reports on $10,000 or more in cash from
everybody and I think we can enforce it
anybody who wants to do business in the
United States and have
the American clearing hazards and to the
end under the Federal Reserve anybody
wants to have a charted operation in New
York anyone who wants to do business
with a with a US correspondent bank
should be required to file such papers
you'd have a terrific uproar politically
for a while but my hunch is that others
are now getting disturbed by this
traffic also and that it would not be
quite the uproar would have been ten or
fifteen years ago I think it's to
greater transparency in both the banking
industry and the securities business is
going to be required if we're talking
about a more international business and
this is as good an issue to begin with
as any
you're suggesting because those doing
business with United States banks with
our banks are required to make those
reports with the excuse they could be
required under the Bank Secrecy Act of
1970 the fact is that the regulator's
have not required everybody who has a
charter for a branch operation in New
York could be held to that by the by the
secretary of the Treasury under the
bank's secretary on the bone of the Bank
Secrecy Act of 1970 and I think it would
be worth doing and it would be worth
taking whatever diplomatic flack there
is I think we would have many more
treaties I do not think that you can
conduct this business from the Isle of
Jersey finally I I think that that
you're going to have to be in some place
which is a real government and that it
should be possible to greatly increase
the transparency of money flows in the
banking system without certain without
any loss to the efficiency of the
operation of the banking system well
let's take a look at what would take
place if we were to undertake that
wouldn't there be easy cry and I'm not
suggesting that we shouldn't I think we
should but that business then we'll move
legitimate businesses as well to other
areas and you would then have the
concern that it would move to Hong Kong
to Japan to London and I don't know what
other major money center areas there are
there may be several others but it would
seem to me that where we to get a
cooperative agreement with those other
major world money centers and implement
this throughout that would really that
would really be the answer I think
you've got to lean on them to have it
happen
I don't think Japan's our problem if
you're in the banking business in Japan
you raise your hand to go to the
bathroom the government is not the
government can handle Japan wouldn't be
a problem Hong Kong over time is not a
problem simply because Hong Kong is
is not going to survive as a really
major financial center once the
Communists take over Singapore
conceivably but it's pretty inconvenient
at small-potatoes
London in a funny way is the worst
problem the the the but the but the Bank
of England has become much more
sympathetic and weak under the under the
Securities and Investments Act the
British agreed to report on euro bond
transactions to print the transactions
that was part of the legislation that
part of the legislation has now been
suspended because the Secretary of State
for whatever it was in the Department of
Trade and Industry decided that London
might lose business so actually our
people first first Boston bullied the
British out of it jock Hennessy there
the Bank of England historically has
taken the position that they don't care
what people do in currencies other than
the pound so long as they don't frighten
the horses and I had thought there was a
change in that and I think that there is
an emerging change but we would have to
require the Bank of England to cooperate
in supervising foreign banks in London
in order to make this thing go are the
Bank of England has become sufficiently
upset about the instability of the
international banking system about all
the contingent liabilities on people's
books about the Mickey Mouse capital
about all of the things that have been
going on in the 1980s that they are much
more sympathetic now to regulation and
while they do not I think understand the
dimensions of the drug problem as well
in London as they will in a few years
this is probably a pretty good time
since there's so many cooperative
ventures going on perhaps under the
aegis of the Bank for International
Settlements in Basel and the survivors
of the cook committee something could be
worked out we are what we're talking
about is to a large extent of
prophylactic matter here in that once
the requirements are there and once
people are afraid not to report you're
not talking about a huge bureaucracy to
enforce it you're talking about
something that is generally under
good if you're going to have an
international financial structure of the
kind that all these guys think we're
going to have I'm not quite so certain
as some of them are then you're going to
have to have much greater access to
information about how the money is
flowing and where then we have had up to
now let me give you a hypothetical could
someone for example with the drug
money's go to a foreign bank today and
let's say can convert those that cash
into a euro bond and have that
undeposited in a in another country for
vanderloos what children it's absolutely
there's no reporting of that whatsoever
there is nothing done in the euro bond
market and the effort to do that as of
this month we're going to start has now
collapsed this is still a market that
leaves no fingerprints so a
sophisticated money-laundering operation
could very easily be pouring billions of
dollars into not just the traditional
shipment or wiring of dollars from one
institution to another but could be
converting those dollars into euro
dollars euro bonds into any variety of
various currencies and was literally no
reporting requirements to date right
that's right but once again these are
dollars they pass through New York and
the Clearing House even though the bonds
are purchased in London it is still
possible in London tried to have a
dollar clearing and it failed back in
the 70s I you cannot do a dollar
clearing operation essentially you can
you can you can do a bond clearing
operation Morgan Guaranty clears
two-thirds of all the euro bond trades
through an operation in Brussels the
operation is in Brussels because Britain
has a staff tax on the transfer of
securities you know you talk about what
drives business out they employ more
than 500 people in Brussels clearing
euro bond transactions and the the the
volume is in the many billions every
night but the money to pay for that
comes through chips in New York arm and
it would be very difficult for them to
find
alternative for it you know when a
company goes into chapter 11 in this
country and it has a euro bond issue it
is common experience that a certain
fraction of those euro bonds not and
sometimes a fairly large one does not
turn up to claim its share of the
proceeds simply because the guys who own
those euro bonds which are bearer bonds
that want to be seen coming into court
this market wants policing also it's by
no means only the banks but the hook
that you got the lever is through the
movement of funds through the Clearing
House interbank payment system and
Fedwire in New York and that's under the
control of the Federal Reserve System
well your main point I take it mr. mayor
is that all dollars come home to the
United States eventually and we can
regulate those dollars if we really have
the political will to a deal with some
of the problems some of the problems
will be the cry from some of our
investment banking houses in others that
we may lose businesses and yacht to
which the answer essentially is we don't
want this business it is it it comes at
too high a price and also if this is
what you're saying is legitimate
business is really not going to move
either of these requirements I don't
think it is I really don't think it is
the I think there will be noises made ah
but no it's not going to move and if it
does move you know they can run but they
can't hide even Hong Kong you can't hide
this is it it's it's possible to lean on
the on the chartering authorities
elsewhere it's not we are we are not
necessarily alone unless we have this
feeling that we are but we are not
necessarily a lot I think that that you
could convince the British that this is
a real problem and that they're going to
have it - let me just ask you if I might
because I believe that in the in this
area we can make our greatest impact you
can arrest all the street corner dealers
and all of the pilots who fly the drugs
in there's always going to be someone
willing and ready and almost anxious to
take their place that this is an area
we have to long-neglected and our and
our efforts should be undertaken and
that's the test by the way if we're
going to fight the drug war in this
terrorist network that is fed in some
part in a substantial degree at times
from the huge profits that come that
give them the ability to buy arms and
people and put organizations together
why we may have to ruffle some feathers
those of the banking industries etc here
at home and and some of our allies and
that's the way to find out so if someone
is an ally whether they're going to join
in these endeavors
you mentioned Luxembourg could you touch
on that for a while why do you suspect
it that maybe that's very strong bank
secrecy laws there again you have a
situation where the financial services
industry has a an unusually large
fraction of employment it's not it's not
Panama by any means you don't have local
corruption you've had some very serious
scandals there which have also alerted
people to the danger I mean the Banco
Ambrosiano scandal the Vatican Bank
business all of these things essentially
filtered through Luxembourg vatican bank
of course also was a Panamanian
operation that was the black hole down
which some hundreds of millions of the
Pope's money disappeared and there it's
a matter I suspect of getting together
with our common market allies and
friends and once again the Bank for
International Settlements and changing
the house rules a little we change the
house rules in Luxembourg
after the Ambrosiano fiasco and the
question of who stands responsible for
their branches in Luxembourg has well
not entirely been cleared up it is much
more cleared up under these
circumstances I think for these guys to
try to do more than temporarily moving
the business under the shield of bank
secrecy laws and Luxembourg probably
wouldn't work because those laws could
be got to change but one would have to
monitor it and of course one has to mind
the crazy places like Lichtenstein also
but these are this is a this this is
doable or it would require it would
require taking it seriously it's
extremely difficult to get banking
regulators to take something like this
seriously that's going to take one other
thing if we're able to begin to isolate
the number of financial institutions or
clearing houses that would handle this
kind of drug drug money
it is a rather not too difficult then to
cut them off from legitimate business as
well isn't it I think so I think that a
great deal can be done if you are
determined enough to do it and if you're
prepared to pay some temporary price for
doing it well mr. mayor I'm going to
thank you over here to the committee for
your well for your testimony today I'm
wondering if you have any other sorts
before you conclude that you don't want
to leave us with I you know I I don't
know much of I don't know anything about
drugs really I know something about
banks and you are this is a tiny piece
of your problem but just seems to me
that it's an extremely important piece
because if you can disrupt the money
flows you can disrupt this operation at
least as easily as you can by just by
disrupting some of the flow of a
narcotics um so I would look forward
hopefully having our staff on the
banking committee to meet with you and
work with you to develop old friends
Amash or some of these some of these
suggestions that we would hopefully be
able to get the regulator's and Treasury
to consider to begin to implement I
don't even think it's legislation in
many cases as you've indicated is by way
of the regulator and I want to commend
Senator Kerry for for bringing you in
today to shed some additional light on
how we can better handle this this
problem
Thank You mr. mayor I apologize for
having to depart momentarily I just had
a long conversation with one of our good
US attorneys here and hopefully we are
progressing forward on some other
matters but I do want to thank you very
much for taking the time to come in I
understand that your testimony that I
didn't hear was extremely helpful in
very thorough thank you very much sir we
are going to take a five minute recess
while we prepare for the testimony mr.
Vogel we stand in recess for five
minutes